最誇張我們病人來跟我說
但他是一個晚上
怎麼去幫忙病人的不舉問題
很像女生就會做鳳凰電波拉皮
幫助他下面保持年輕
下一個選項叫做
它不保證你的壓力不會超標
你就想是你的生殖器壓力大到一個程度
可能會
所以就是非常的危險
男生的攝護腺肥大是這樣
其實攝護腺肥大不會怎麼樣
早點解決
可以減少很多問題
您現在收看的是精華版
如果要看完整版的話
請點擊下方連結
加入官方Line
Hi 大家好
我是宋晏仁 宋醫師
歡迎來到初日會客室
今天我們來談談
男性專屬的議題
本集是 Men's Talk
為您請到的是很 Man
又很顧家的好醫生
人家叫他鳥醫生
顧家醫療的總院長
顧醫師好
大家好
我是鳥科學先生
泌尿科顧芳瑜醫師
我是顧家醫療總院長
我想進入一個更多人不敢講
勃起功能障礙的
也就是我們常說不舉
什麼叫做不舉
你只要
包含你很難插入
或者是你插入之後很容易就軟掉
這些其實都廣義來講算是我們的
性功能障礙的一個範疇
性功能障礙包含了勃起的問題
包含了硬度的問題
包含了太快 早洩的問題
包含了太慢 射不出來的問題
包含了性慾減退的問題
性交疼痛
勃起到底要多硬才算是正常
我們有四個分類
我們叫做勃起硬度的測量
或者叫做豆腐
最軟的
就是有一點軟好像有充血的感覺
就是有一點硬度了 但是好像還不夠硬
所以你可以利用這四種常見的食物
來判斷你的硬度到什麼程度
就基本上你在帶皮香蕉之上
你就可以插入了
只是可能會覺得不夠
或者是可能另一半會覺得
感覺不夠明顯
那當然最好就是小黃瓜
可能就真的是有問題
那當然如果大家會擔心就是
你只要沒有小黃瓜其實都可以來檢查
因為有一些人是早期的血管性的問題
他可能剛開始是慢慢變軟
早期治療他就可以回到小黃瓜
所以到了蒟蒻那個程度就相當嚴重
相當嚴重
不舉既然是蠻常見的問題
您覺得可能的原因大概是什麼
然後泌尿科怎麼樣來協助治療
勃起功能障礙
其實有兩個大類的原因
心因性的問題大家比較好理解
有時候就是伴侶關係啦
那另外一方面就是器質性
又可以分成兩大類
神經性的問題比較少見
它大部分就是如果你有一些脊椎損傷
比如說車禍或者是中風
血管性的問題大概佔 80%
它又可以分為幾個原因
包含了糖尿病的問題
肥胖的問題
荷爾蒙下降的問題
都有可能會影響你血管的活性
血管的彈性不好了
或是血管硬化了
或血管萎縮了
那就會導致你想要興奮的時候
你的血液沒有辦法衝進你的海綿體裡面
就會有硬不起來的問題
怎麼去幫忙病人的不舉問題
第一件事情我們一定會抽全套的血
包含了他的一些代謝性的疾病
比如說膽固醇的問題
血脂肪的問題
血糖的問題
甚至甲狀腺我們也會檢查
因為有些人他可能是甲狀腺低下
造成的勃起功能障礙
連甲狀腺低下也會造成勃起功能障礙
也會造成勃起功能障礙
然後還有荷爾蒙的問題
男性荷爾蒙
那包含攝護腺的癌指數我們也會做
因為有一些人他可能其實根本是
潛在攝護腺癌
他攝護腺還壓迫到他的神經了
所以我們希望可以早點發現這個問題
如果他有代謝性的疾病
我們可能會先藥物治療
然後會建議他要養成良好的生活習慣
包含要養成固定的運動
飲食上的控制
都會讓他的勃起的功能會慢慢的恢復
不過在我們這邊
我們還是可以做的另外一件事情
就是我們要
怎麼做呢
我們會讓病人吃低劑量的犀利士類的藥物
這類藥物作用時間是 24 個鐘頭
也就是說他只要吃一顆藥
他整天的血管都會容易有擴張的情況
那會讓他的末梢血液循環會比較容易改善
真的要性行為的時候他會比較開心
因為表現就會變得比較好
除了吃藥之外
我們會建議他同時搭配
另外一種物理治療
就是一個震動的探頭
會貼在我們陰莖的海綿體上面
破壞我們海綿體的一些小血管
讓它重新生長
重新生長之後你血管變多了
變得比較健康
你的充血能力就會恢復了
那你就可能可以減少藥物的使用
通常這個治療它需要多長的時間
效果可以維持多久
一個禮拜一次
然後我們做到 12 次的治療
差不多三個月
那一次的話大概是 15 到 20 分鐘
看每個機器不同
你的藥物使用會減少
或者是你可能原本吃藥沒效
做了之後吃藥有效
它改善會從比如說蒟蒻變成小黃瓜嗎
可能會升一級到兩級
可能會從蒟蒻升到帶皮香蕉
或到脫皮香蕉
或者是說你從原本的脫皮香蕉
會變到小黃瓜
這個 60% 有效的人大概維持多久
目前的研究是大概
60% 到 90% 的人可以維持一年
那 50% 的人可以維持兩年
很像女生就會做鳳凰電波拉皮
男生就是做陰莖震波也是拉皮
幫助他下面保持年輕
我聽說有這個真空助勃
對
如果你是藥物跟低能量震波
效果都不理想
下一個選項叫做
它比較有趣
它是一個抽真空的裝置
放在我們陰莖外面
它會抽真空
血液就會灌進我們的陰莖海綿體裡面
你就會硬起來了
那硬起來之後呢 廠商就會附一個
矽膠的橡皮筋
可以綁起來
對 把後面綁起來
那你就是金槍不倒
你要大戰個 30 回合都沒有關係
它絕對不會軟下來
那這個需要醫師處方嗎
原則上這個東西是要醫師處方的
但是很多人他會去上網查
就會發現外面網購好像有賣類似的東西
情趣商店也有
對 情趣商店也有賣類似的東西
那我為什麼要花這麼多錢去買一個醫療用品
因為這其實也是幾萬塊的東西
這個東西它是有安全裝置的
經過衛福部認證
所以它是一個醫療級的東西
可是你買了情趣用品
它不保證你的壓力不會超標
你就想是你的生殖器壓力大到一個程度
可能會
啪一聲就破了
所以就是非常的危險
所以會建議大家
所以如果你真的需要治療
還是需要買正規的醫療用品
才能達到一定程度的安全性
避免併發症的發生
那相較於這個低能量震波
真空助勃器的有效性有多少
要看怎麼定義有效啦
如果以可以硬 可以用來講
目前大概 80% 到 90% 的病人
用都是有效的
真的沒效代表你的那個纖維化
已經非常嚴重了
我們就會建議下一步
叫做人工陰莖的裝置
那我們再來談談人工陰莖怎麼弄
我先講就是
我們很多病人就說要裝人工陰莖
那我是不是整副都要切掉
然後我裝一個塑膠的在上面
不是喔
我們常說的人工陰莖
其實它的正式名稱叫做
裝在這（海綿體）裡面
你就可以真正取代你勃起的這個功能
你就可以性行為了
平常就是硬的
所以你只要褲子脫下來就可以使用
就不需要再等它勃起
那我們來談談就是說
性功能障礙
比如說你剛講早洩 遲射
性交疼痛
它大概的原因是什麼
其實呢早洩嚴格來說
因為動物在性交的時候最容易被天敵捕獲
所以自然界衍生出一個法則
怎麼樣讓你的子孫
讓你的 DNA 可以容易流傳到後世呢
所以我們人類也是啊
我們也是動物的一環
那只是說因為我們是現在是高等動物
我們不會被吃掉了嘛
所以我們才會追求時間要慢（口誤）
所以現在有延緩射精的藥物
有 有延緩射精的藥物
是哪類的藥物
我們叫做 Dapoxetine
它其實是一個
血清素的一個藥物
為什麼呢
因為其實
我們的大腦會分泌血清素這個物質
當你這個物質不足的時候
你的射精控制就會不好
你就很容易會射精
我們的大腦就是我們的水壩
當你的水壩的水淹過這個水壩的時候
你就會射精了
那所以我們有兩種讓你的時間變久的方法
一個就是吃藥
就是剛剛講
我們會吃一些血清素延長的藥物
讓我們大腦的血清素增加
你就想像我們的壩體就會增高
所以我們的水就不容易淹過去
那當然如果不想要吃這個藥呢
另外一種做法就是我們讓水壩的水減少
就是我們會用一些抗敏感的噴霧
噴在我們的生殖器上面
讓你的刺激減少
水減少了 你就比較不容易射精
多早叫做早洩
叫做早洩
醫學上最嚴格定義從插入到射精
一分鐘以內就算是早洩
我們蠻多病人會來說
喔 我自己 DIY 的時候很快
那我是不是早洩
不算喔
這樣不算早洩
在生活上
我們覺得有一個比較廣義的定義
我認為是五分鐘啦
就是如果你在五分鐘以內出來
就算是太快
超過五分鐘以上
基本上就沒什麼太大問題了
就算正常了
有些人就是
他一直不射精的
遲射就是早洩的反面啦
遲射的定義呢 是從插入到射出
超過 30 分鐘以上
就叫做遲射了
跟一些心理壓力或是跟一些生理的壓力
可能是有關係的
我們都會建議病人要去做心理諮商
那如果說你覺得
其實我心理上沒有什麼太大疙瘩啊
我們也可以嘗試用一些藥物治療
有一些藥物它的副作用是早洩
像是第一代的抗組織胺
所以我們會吃這個藥來讓病人提早射精
看能不能解決他這個問題
中高齡的男生最常看到就是
攝護腺的問題
可不可以談一下在台灣
盛行的情況如何
主要發生的原因是什麼
男生的攝護腺肥大
發生率是這樣子
40 歲是 40% 的人會有這個問題
50 歲 50% 60 歲 60%
70 歲 70%
80 歲就是 80% 了
所以
這是我們老師跟我們講的至理名言
它有幾個常見的原因
因為攝護腺會增長
因為男性荷爾蒙經年累月的刺激
我們的攝護腺細胞 它就會增生
細胞越來越多 它就會越來越大
因為我們的攝護腺
其實是包著我們的尿道的
在我們膀胱的下方
所以攝護腺肥大的症狀
某些人有一些基因
它會造成容易有遺傳性的
第三個大家常常會忽略的問題
目前也認為有一些
比如說
你的飲食中如果肉含量
跟脂肪含量是比較高的
比較容易刺激攝護腺去生長
你就比較容易有攝護腺肥大的問題
在一般的日常生活當中
民眾該怎麼自己知道
有攝護腺肥大的問題
什麼時候應該要就診
其實攝護腺再怎麼大
因為它既不會痛 你也不會不舒服
你也手摸不到
攝護腺肥大會有哪些常見的症狀
因為肥大的關係阻塞你的膀胱
所以每一次排尿的時候都會尿不乾淨
你就會有一些殘尿
有殘尿 膀胱容易滿漲
你就容易又想要上廁所
你就會覺得你的水柱很弱
沒辦法掃射你的馬桶
剛好有蒼蠅你就掃不到牠
以前一覺到天亮
現在一個晚上可能會爬起來兩次三次
最誇張我們病人來跟我說
他是一夜七次郎
但他是一個晚上爬起來尿尿七次
這三個可以說是最常見
再來有一些比較沒有那麼常見
比如說尿不乾淨
或者是尿尿會斷斷續續的
或者是想尿的時候會憋不太住
這些都是跟攝護腺肥大有關的症狀
什麼時候需要就醫呢
如果你開始覺得好像有這樣的症狀
就可以來初步做檢查
大部分的病人都會覺得沒關係
他可能撐個好幾年之後來做
哇 攝護腺已經超級大了
這個時候要再做一些簡單的治療
其實都很困難
到最後就是直接開刀而已
其實攝護腺肥大不會怎麼樣
所以久了之後膀胱功能越來越差
很多時候開完刀之後病人還是尿不出來
因為他的膀胱已經全部無力了
已經壞掉了
他早點解決
他其實可以減少很多問題
對 可是等你拖到都已經壞掉的時候
其實醫生也救不回來了
請您介紹一下
攝護腺的手術有哪一些方法
第一個大家可能會最常聽到就是雷射
雷射一直推陳出新
它可以減少掉不必要的破壞
我們最近這幾年又有更新的東西
叫做微創手術
它用 104 度的水蒸氣注射
注射到攝護腺裡面之後
它的溫度會快速從 104 度下降到 70 度
這個溫差讓我們的細胞
受到熱傷害
這個細胞會自動凋亡
所以它是一個
這樣的好處是什麼呢
第一個手術 30 分鐘之內一定會結束
做完之後我們會讓病人放個尿管
然後他就在恢復室觀察個半個小時
沒有問題就帶著尿管回家
而且水蒸氣不會流血
但是還是有人說我不要放尿管啊
那怎麼辦呢
有另外一種方式
它是用一個 H 型的鋼釘
然後中間會有一條很特殊的縫線
我們會把它釘在我們的攝護腺的肉裡面
它會把攝護腺
阻塞處拉開來而已
這是美國發明的
做這種方式呢 連尿管都不用放
哇 聽起來好吸引人喔
做完就回家
非常的方便
最近幾年其實有更多的男性
更年期這個議題被討論
您怎麼定義男性更年期
有什麼樣的程度或症狀就應該要就診
有一個量表叫做 ADAM
包含了容易疲倦 容易累
做事情沒有活力 沒有動力
吃飽飯容易想睡覺
性慾減退 勃起功能障礙
體重增加 骨質疏鬆
我們就可以診斷為男性更年期
三高
是不是通常也跟它比較有關係
對
有三高的病人
如果同時發現他也有荷爾蒙低下的問題
在他補充了荷爾蒙之後
他的三高控制會變得比較好
會幫助你一些慢性疾病的控制
所以它跟骨質疏鬆也有關係嗎
對 其實這個東西跟骨質疏鬆也有關係
骨質在你的國高中階段之後
骨質就不會再回升了 它只會流失而已
所以
因為你容易骨折
骨折你可能就臥床不起
你可能很容易就會有生命的危險
所以睪固酮低下
其實真的不是只有性功能的低下
或是一些情緒的問題
還牽涉到生命的長短
對 還牽涉到生命的長短
哇 真的滿重要的
最後來賓我們都會有一個
快問快答的段落
日常生活中怎麼樣改善攝護腺肥大
最主要能夠做的事情就是飲食
就可以盡量減少攝護腺肥大的問題
頻尿有可能是心理問題嗎
排除心理問題之外
其實很多時候跟你的攝護腺肥大
跟你的膀胱本身的神經有關係
真的有頻尿的困擾
建議還是找醫師做檢查
男生常會用比大小
什麼樣的尺寸算不正常
臨床上的定義
是說如果
那就可能真的是有陰莖短小的問題
除此之外都是沒有問題的
有可能透過手術來改變陰莖大小嗎
確實 我們現在有這類的手術
包含我們有陰莖增粗的手術
有陰莖增長的手術
我們會盡量在安全範圍內
讓它的體積盡量變大
滿足大家的需求
吃壯陽藥會不會對藥物產生依賴
應該說它不會有生理上的依賴
很多時候是心理上的依賴
A 片看太多會導致性功能障礙嗎
沒有那麼簡單
不過當然如果你真的是
重度的情色片成癮
確實可能會有一些心理上的問題
可能會導致你有一些勃起功能障礙的問題
打手槍的頻率
怎麼樣才是在合理的範圍
這個在西醫觀點是沒有特別限定的
所以其實
你想要一年一次
你想要一天很多次
如果你是打手槍到
你不打你會覺得有點像戒斷症
那可能就要去治療了
在性行為之後會出現血精現象
算正常嗎
這個偶爾會遇到
什麼叫良性血精
因為我們精液在射出的時候
大量的精液會沖過我們的攝護腺
有一些時候攝護腺的黏膜層
被這個精液沖到 它可能破皮了
就會產生血精的狀況
休息一個月或兩個禮拜
讓你的黏膜可以修復
其實就會回到正常的狀況了
精液量的多寡跟健康狀況有關嗎
不一定
大部分的精液
它其實主要是前列腺的分泌物
跟尿道球腺的分泌物
你可能單一次
比較沒有那麼興奮
你的分泌物就會不夠
下一次可能比較興奮
分泌物就會比較多
所以沒有辦法很好的
來表達你身體的狀況
哪一個衛教知識你覺得很重要
但是卻常常被忽略
喔 其實超多的
我覺得最重要就是大家
要對自己身體的基本照顧要有一定認識
包含包皮怎麼清潔
包含性行為是怎麼回事
怎麼樣預防性傳染病
我覺得這個都是
當今社會目前非常重要的一個議題
我們有一些病人 不孕夫妻
結婚了 3、5 年都沒有懷孕
結果後來發現
原來他根本沒有順利插進洞裡面
當然不會懷孕啊
所以我覺得蠻多東西
都是需要去學習的
哇 我覺得今天的 Men's talk
真的是得到好多
男生不知道的知識
甚至說男醫生都不知道的知識
謝謝你今天來我們的初日會客室
謝謝您 謝謝